bonjour à tous
aujourd'hui on va parler de Nietzsche
on a déjà parlé plusieurs fois de
Nietzsche sur cette chaîne on a déjà
expliqué les grandes lignes de sa pensée
et notamment son concept clé la volonté
de puissance
on a vu en quoi ce concept de volonté de
puissance était au cœur de la vision ni
chaîne du monde
et qu'il permettait de comprendre sa
pensée sur à peu près tous les sujets
que ce soit la métaphysique la morale ou
la religion
mais aujourd'hui on va voir ce qu'il en
est de la vision de Nietzsche à propos
d'un autre domaine à savoir le domaine
de l'art
Nietzsche s'intéressait beaucoup à l'art
en particulier à la musique
on connaît son admiration pour le
compositeur Richard Wagner avec lequel
il fut d'ailleurs ami avant de s'en
éloigner
et pour Nietzsche l'art n'est pas
seulement une activité essentielle à
l'homme
l'art c'est ni plus ni moins que
l'expression de la vie
autrement dit l'art c'est la seule chose
qui compte vraiment
habituellement le philosophe est celui
qui recherche la vérité
il est celui qui place la vérité
au-dessus de tout
et bien pour Nietzsche l'art est
au-dessus de la vérité
il le dit textuellement dans ses
fragments posthume nous avons l'art pour
ne pas mourir de la vérité
c'est pas banal
et donc ce qui va intéresser Nietzsche
c'est de comprendre ce qui s'exprime à
travers l'art
c'est de comprendre comment la vie
s'exprime à travers l'art
et pour ça il va forger de notions
auquel on va s'intéresser aujourd'hui à
savoir le dionysiaque et l'apolline
alors vous verrez qu'on trouve parfois
le mot dionysien au lieu de dionysiaque
dans les textes de Nietzsche mais ça n'a
pas d'importance
l'important c'est de comprendre ce que
signifie ces deux termes et de
comprendre en quoi leur porter ne se
limite pas au domaine de l'art mais
qu'il renvoie à deux principes de vie
Nietzsche est un penseur de la vie c'est
quelqu'un qui a cherché à comprendre
l'essence de la vie son essence profonde
et pour lui la plupart des philosophes
se sont trompés en voulant théoriser la
vie
en voulant l'intellectualiser
parce que intellectualisé c'est déjà
transformé
c'est déjà des former
on aime bien intellectualiser les choses
parce que ça fait bien ça impressionne
ça fait intelligent
oui mais sauf que pour Nietzsche
intellectualiser la vie
c'est passé complètement à côté de ce
qu'est la vie
c'est d'ailleurs pourquoi l'artiste
n'intellectualise pas
il crée
comme la vie crée
et quand l'artiste crée c'est la vie
elle-même qui s'exprime à travers lui
et c'est ça que Nietzsche va tenter de
nous expliquer
alors pour donner un peu le contexte on
est en 1872 nitcha 28 ans et il vient de
publier son premier livre qui s'intitule
la naissance de la tragédie
à cette époque Nietzsche est encore
professeur de philologie à l'université
de balle en Suisse
je rappelle que la philologie c'est
l'étude des œuvres de l'Antiquité
grecque et latine
c'est l'équivalent de ce qu'on
appellerait aujourd'hui les lettres
classiques
donc il y a chez Nietzsche une véritable
passion pour l'Antiquité en particulier
pour l'Antiquité grecque
mais l'originalité de Nietzsche c'est
qu'il ne se contente pas simplement
d'étudier les œuvres de l'Antiquité
il se demande ce qu'elles expriment
philosophiquement
il se demande ce que les Grecs avaient
compris sur le monde
et si on va aller plus loin nietz se
demande ce que les Grecs avaient compris
et que nous avons oublié
ou que nous avons rejeté
donc il n'aborde plus l'Antiquité
seulement comme philologue il aborde
comme philosophe
comme quelqu'un qui s'interroge sur la
nature du monde et de la vie
et la thèse de Nietzsche consiste à dire
que ce qu'avait compris les Grecs et que
l'Occident moderne a oublié c'est que la
vie est tragique
que l'essence de la vie c'est son
caractère tragique
la vie est tragique ça veut dire que
l'homme ne peut pas lutter contre les
forces de la vie
l'orgueil nous fait croire qu'on
pourrait aller contre notre destin
qu'on pourrait maîtriser notre destin
mais non
la vie est plus forte que nous
c'est toujours elle qui gagne à la fin
le héros tragique c'est celui qui fait
tout pour échapper à son destin
et qui en vient au sentiment les plus
désespérés
parce qu'ils seront bien compte que la
vie est plus forte que lui
le héros tragique refuse le tragique
et c'est ça qui rend sa condition
d'autant plus tragique
parce qu'il se dresse contre des forces
dont il ne peut pas triompher
les Grecs avaient compris ça
et nous nous l'avons oublié
nous l'avons oublié ou plutôt nous avons
fait en sorte de l'oublier parce que
vivre en ayant conscience que la vie est
tragique ce n'est pas supportable
donc qu'est-ce que nous avons fait
nous avons recouvert le tragique
nous l'avons recouvert
d'apparence et d'illusions
des illusions comme la raison la justice
la vérité le bien
toutes ces notions qui donnent du sens à
la vie pour mieux nous faire oublier que
la vie est absurde
comme le dit Nietzsche l'absurdité d'une
chose n'est pas une raison contre son
existence
son est une condition
nous rejetons l'absurde parce que
l'absurde nous effraie parce que
l'absurde nous donne le vertige au lieu
d'embrasser le vertige
le vertige n'est un problème que
lorsqu'on cherche à l'éviter
les vitesses l'apostrophe
et donc c'est ça qui fait dire à
Nietzsche que le monde est gouverné par
deux forces fondamentales
la force chaotique de Dionysos
et la force ordonnatrice d'Apollon
une force Tab surdité qui est au
fondement de toutes choses
et une force de recouvrement de
l'absurdité
qui permet de la supporter
et ce sont ces deux forces qui
fusionnent dans la tragédie grecque à
savoir le dionysiaque et la Pauline
donc bien entendu on va expliquer en
détail ce que sont ces deux forces
mais déjà vous voyez ce que je vous
disais tout à l'heure à savoir que le
dionysiaque et la polynien ne sont pas
des notions seulement liées à l'art
ce ne sont pas seulement les catégories
esthétiques
ce sont des forces fondamentales du
monde et de la vie
donc quand Nietzsche parle d'art
il ne parle pas seulement d'art
il parle de la vie elle-même
il parle de ce qui anime le monde
de ce qui anime la nature
et donc par extension de ce qui anime
l'homme
est entendu que l'homme est un produit
de la nature
donc à chaque fois que l'homme agit
c'est la nature qui agit à travers lui
donc maintenant ça va être le moment
d'expliquer ce que ninch appelle le
dionysiaque et la polynéen
on va prendre le temps qu'il faut pour
que tout ça soit bien clair et pour ça
on va commencer par parler de l'art
classique
l'art classique c'est un mouvement qui
s'est développé en Europe au 17e siècle
et qui repose sur la recherche de
l'ordre de la beauté et de l'équilibre
l'art classique c'est le respect des
règles
c'est pour ça qu'on parle des règles de
la bienséance au théâtre
ou de la règle des trois unités
parce qu'il y a chez les classiques un
souci de l'ordre
de la régularité
règles régulières c'est le même mot
donc pour le dire le plus simplement
possible
dans l'art classique on ne fait pas
n'importe quoi
on ne met pas la fin avant le début
on ne mélange pas les gens
et d'une manière générale on soigne la
forme
la devise des classiques c'est plaire et
instruire
or on ne plaît pas avec du désordre
on ne plaît pas avec de la difformité
avec de la laideur
alors on peut ne pas être d'accord avec
ça
mais c'est comme ça qu'on voyait les
choses chez les classiques
en peinture on tâche de représenter des
scènes harmonieuses
avec des visages au traits réguliers
les teintes sont lumineuses
les éléments sont symétriques
même chose en architecture
vous voyez à quoi ressemble les façades
à colonnes les colonnades
bon bien ça c'est typique de
l'architecture classique
les colonnes c'est la grandeur
c'est la stabilité
c'est l'harmonie
d'ailleurs quand on parle de beauté en
art on se réfère généralement à la
définition classique de la beauté
c'est à dire à l'harmonie
l'harmonisation c'est l'art de
l'ajustement
c'est l'art de la combinaison
en musique on parle d'harmonie quand les
sons Concorde
quand il s'ajuste de manière à produire
un effet agréable à l'oreille
donc sans entrer davantage dans les
détails je pense que vous avez compris
l'idée l'arc classique c'est la beauté
et l'ordre
et bien ça nous dit Nietzsche c'est la
Pauline
la Pauline c'est une approche artistique
c'est une attitude esthétique
fondée sur la recherche de l'harmonie
donc la référence à Polon vient du fait
qu'Apollon c'était le dieu de la beauté
c'était aussi le dieu de la lumière
un dieu solaire
tout ça ça va ensemble
beauté lumière ordre
mais aussi raison
le mouvement philosophique des lumières
c'est le mouvement de la raison
et la poésie c'est là aussi un art fondé
sur le respect de certaines règles
ce qu'on appelle la versification
l'écriture en verre
la maîtrise si la bique le fait que les
vers doivent comporter le même nombre de
syllabes
le schéma des rimes
les rémeyant pour fonction non seulement
de produire un son agréable agréable
parce que rythmiquement régulier
mais qui aussi souligne et renforce la
structure métrique
donc il y a une vraie codification
formelle de l'art poétique
là encore on ne fait pas n'importe quoi
quand Verlaine s'est amusé à écrire des
poèmes avec des vers de 9 syllabes ça a
été le branle-bas de combat
on s'est dit mais qu'est-ce qu'il nous
fait
9 syllabes c'est moche
c'est pas symétrique
oui mais justement
Verlaine contestée les règles de
l'écriture classique
c'était volontaire
pour en revenir à Apollon Apollon c'est
l'emblème de l'équilibre et de la beauté
formelle
et d'ailleurs quand on dit d'un homme
que c'est un Apollon c'est pour dire
qu'il a un physique harmonieux et
attrayant
un beau corps
bien dessiné bien proportionné
et bien ça pour Nietzsche ce monde
apollinien
ce monde de la régularité de la symétrie
de la mesure
c'est tout ce qu'il rejette
alors je le dis de manière un peu
brutale pour vous faire comprendre
l'idée en réalité c'est un peu plus
subtil que ça
Nietzsche ne rejette pas exactement la
Pauline
mais il constate que la polynien rejette
tout ce qui n'est pas harmonieux
que la pollinien rejette le spontané
l'irrégulier
le difforme
la polynien rejette le relief
il est lisse
trop lisse
trop lisse pour ne pas cacher quelque
chose
pour ne pas dissimuler quelque chose
on verra ça tout à l'heure
toujours est-il que Nietzsche constate
que la polynéen ce n'est pas ça la vie
la vie n'est pas faite de symétrie
d'ordre et de beauté
la vie est faite d'aspérité
d'irrégularité
de creux et de bosses
la vie n'est pas faite que de raison
elle est faite de passion
elle est faite de ce que j'appelle du
dionysiaque
Bacchus chez les Romains c'était le Dieu
de l'ivresse
le dieu des excès de la démesure
de la folie
c'est Apollon incarne la raison je Lisos
incarne la déraison
il y avait autrefois en Grèce qu'on
appelait les Dionysies
les dionysis c'était des cérémonies
religieuses je mets des guillemets au
cours desquels on se livrait à tous les
excès
musique 20
débauche sexuelles transmise
la fête quoi
alors il n'y avait pas que ça
il y avait aussi des concours de théâtre
parce que Dionysos c'est aussi le dieu
du théâtre
et la fonction des dionysis outre de
rendre un culte à la divinité Dionysos
c'était
d'expurger les passions
et ainsi de réguler l'ordre social
le surplus d'énergie était dépensé et
une fois les excès terminés
on reprenait la vie normale
le retour à l'équilibre
le retour à la polynien
donc en définitive le couple Apollon
Dionysos
c'est la figuration de la dualité de la
vie
la raison et la passion
la sobriété et l'ivresse
la mesure
et l'excès
on fera tout à l'heure la liste
détaillée des antinomies entre la
polliniens et le dionysiaque
et vous verrez que ça va beaucoup plus
loin que ce qu'on pourrait croire et que
c'est vraiment quelque chose qui
structure l'intégralité de la vie et du
monde
mais avant ça je vais dire quelques mots
sur Socrate alors pourquoi Socrate
parce que Nietzsche détestait Socrate
il le détestait parce qu'il voyait dans
Socrate un apollinien qui a converti la
Grèce à la polynisme
on a déjà parlé de Socrate sur cette
chaîne et on a vu que Socrate c'était
quelqu'un qui était attaché au vrai au
bon et au beau
c'était quelqu'un qui était attaché au
juste
le juste sous toutes ses formes
le juste dans la connaissance
le juste dans la morale
le juste dans l'esthétique
la justice autant que la justesse
or le juste c'est une notion
apollinienne
le juste repose sur des règles
les règles du Logos c'est à dire de la
rationalité
les règles morales
le fait par exemple de ne pas causer de
souffrance à autrui
les règles du beau
l'harmonie la mesure
l'excellence
Socrate est celui qui a donné ses
lettres de noblesse à la raison
après son procès et sa condamnation à
mort sa pensée fut pour ainsi dire
réhabiliter
on reconnut en lui un homme de bien
un modèle intellectuel et moral
et ce fut la fin nous dit Nietzsche de
l'apogée dionysiaque
la fin de la célébration des forces
vitales de l'excès
on devint mesurer
sage
discipliné
les premiers héritiers du socratisme ce
sont les stoïciens
des hommes qui voient dans l'excès un
penchant à fuir
horreur l'excès
horreur la démesure
horreur la passion
pour Nietzsche en condamnant de Dionysos
Socrate a condamné la vie
au sens où il a condamné le fond
énergétique de ce qui fait la vie
les forces tumultueuses du chaos de
l'ivresse
de la puissance
car pour Nietzsche c'est ça le sous-sol
de l'existence
la puissance
plus exactement
la volonté de puissance
à la fin de sa vie Nietzsche dira que le
dionysiaque et la volonté de puissance
c'est la même chose
la volonté de puissance c'est cette
force qui anime le monde et la vie et
qui pousse toute chose à vouloir croître
et s'étendre
lorsqu'une plante pousse
elle exprime sa volonté de puissance
poussée c'est à la fois s'allonger mais
c'est aussi faire pression
on pousse pour repousser
pousser c'est faire reculer les limites
pousser et puissance c'est la même chose
c'est la pulsion
ou la pulsation
Dionysos et du côté du cœur
il est du côté de la pulsation
du pathos
Apollon et du côté de l'esprit
le Logos
pour Dionysos les catégories du vrai du
juste ou du bien n'ont aucun sens
parce que la vie est indifférente à ces
catégories
la volonté de puissance qui nous anime
elle est aveugle
elle est sourde aux sollicitations du
Logos
le Logos c'est ce que l'être humain a
inventé pour canaliser le pathos
mais au fondement des choses à la racine
des choses
il y a le pathos
il y a la volonté
il y a la force
et l'homme a inventé la forme pour
maîtriser la force
pour la limiter
pour lui donner des contours
pour la sculpter
pour Nietzsche la sculpture et du côté
de la pollinien parce que la sculpture
donne une forme
elle donne des limites
le pendant de la sculpture c'est la
musique
parce que la musique n'a pas de contour
parce que la musique est vibration
elle est propagation d'énergie
là où la sculpture est fixe la musique
se propage
elle se diffuse
la sculpture reste la musique s'envole
la polliniens ces lettres
le dionysiaque
c'est le devenir
reprenons un peu nos esprits
Nietzsche voyait dans la tragédie
grecque la synthèse du dionysiaque et de
la polyné
la tragédie et dionysiaque au sens où
elle exprime les passions humaines
le désert de domination
le désir de vengeance le désir de
vaincre
le héros tragique est traversé par la
passion
il est le lieu de convergence de toutes
les forces de la nature
Antigone
tous ces personnages sont conduits par
la fatalité
assouvir leur passion
et à en payer le prix
et c'est pour ça qu'on disait que les
tragédies avaient une fonction
cathartique
une fonction de purification des
passions
le spectateur voit ce qu'il advient de
ce que la passion domine
et se faisant ça le calme
ça le libère
les Dionysies avaient la même fonction
de catharsis
on expurge nos passions pour rendre
possible le retour à l'équilibre
donc le dionysiaque et la polynéen sont
complémentaires
la polynien donne un cadre au
dionysiaque
il lui donne une forme
mais le dionysiaque ne peut pas et ne
pourra jamais être supprimé
il peut seulement être canaliser
on ne supprime jamais la pulsion
on lui donne un cadre
on donne un cadre à la volonté de
puissance parce qu'on sait qu'on ne peut
pas l'empêcher de s'exprimer
ceux d'entre vous qui ont lu Freud
auront reconnu la dualité ça sur moi
le ça c'est la partie du psychisme qui
héberge nos désirs
nos désirs inavouables et donc
inassouvissable
sur moi c'est la partie du psychisme qui
dicte la loi
qui autorise et qui interdit
c'est le filtre de nos pulsions
je dis bien filtre et non pas barrage
parce qu'on bloque pas la pulsion
on ne peut que l'encadrer
la formaliser c'est à dire lui donner
une forme
quand on travaille quand on étudie quand
on crée
on formalise notre énergie vitale
l'énergie vitale c'est ce que Freud
appelait la libido
mais Freud n'était pas le premier à
parler de libido
Pascal parler de libido
Saint-Augustin par les libido
et tous deux distinguer trois formes de
libido
la libido scène tiens dit le désir de
plaisir
la libido dominant dit le désir de
domination
la libido sienne dit le désir de
connaissance
or ces trois désirs ont beau se
différencier dans leur forme
ils sont identiques comme force
ce sont simplement trois voies de
canalisation du désir humain
qu'en Freud parlait de sublimation il
parlait d'une manière détournée de
satisfaire son désir
on convertit sa pulsion en énergie de
création
parce que l'expression non canalisée de
la pulsion conduirait au chaos social
elle conduirait à notre mort
et qu'en freud parle de renoncement
pulsionnel il parle du fait de
s'interdire d'assouvir nos forces
dionysiaques au profit du choix
apollinien c'est à dire raisonnable de
la coexistence pacifique
Apollon c'est la tendance raisonnable de
l'homme
Dionysos
c'est la tendance pulsionnelle de
l'homme
or Nietzsche nous dit qu'entre Apollon
et Dionysos
c'est Dionysos qui constitue la force
réellement fondamentale
Apollon n'est qu'un régulier
n'est qu'un détournement et un
rééquilibrage de la pulsion dionysiaque
il faut bien que ce rééquilibrage se
fasse
parce que sinon
c'en est fini de la coexistence
la vie en société ne serait qu'une
interminable dionysie
mais une dionysie peut-elle seulement
être interminable
quand Nietzsche nous dit que le
dionysiaque est plus fondamental que la
polynien
c'est au sens littéral
à savoir que le dionysiaque est au
fondement de la vie
la pulsation est au fondement de la vie
le reste ce n'est que de l'habillage
pour ne pas dire du travestissement
du déguisement
on disait tout à l'heure que la polynéen
avec quelque chose à cacher
la polynien cache le dionysiaque en nous
c'est ce qu'on fait tous
quand on a du désir pour quelqu'un
on ne saute pas dessus
enfin ça dépend mais la première fois on
évite
on y met les formes
les formes apolliniennes
le sourire la politesse
séduire étymologiquement c'est détourner
et la séduction est effectivement une
manière détournée de parvenir à l'acte
sexuel
et donc d'assouvir sa pulsion
alors oui ça fait mauvais genre de dire
ça parce que l'être humain croit dans la
supériorité de ses aspirations
l'être humain aime se voir comme un être
pouvant s'affranchir de ses
déterminations biologiques et
corporelles
grand bien lui en face
mais Nietzsche n'est pas dupe
en bon disciple de chopiner en tout cas
à l'époque où il a écrit la naissance de
la tragédie
nietche est convaincu que c'est une
pulsion dionysiaque qui gouverne nos
comportements
cette pulsion shopenhauer la volonté
est-ce que Nietzsche appelle la polynien
c'est ce que chopenhauer la
représentation
le monde des apparences
les apparences qui recouvrent la réalité
souterraine
la polynien recouvre le dionysiaque
parce que la civilisation est conçue de
telle sorte que nous avons honte de
notre dimension dionysiaque
donc nous la cachons
nous là refoulons
mais refoulé ne signifie pas supprimer
il y a toujours le retour du refoulé
le dionysiaque n'est pas supprimable
il est toujours là
derrière la polynéen qui tente de le
canaliser
je vous disais tout à l'heure qu'on
allait faire une liste détaillée des
antinomies entre le dionysiaque et la
polliniens
c'est le moment
et vous allez voir qu'au fur et à mesure
de cette liste vous allez sans doute
mieux comprendre certaines choses qui
définissent notre condition
la polynéen c'est l'ordre
le dionysiaque c'est le chaos
la polynéen c'est la raison
de tunisiaque c'est la passion
la polynéen c'est la sobriété
le dionysiaque c'est l'ivresse
la polynien c'est la mesure
le dionysiaque c'est l'excès
la polynien c'est la paix
le dionysiaque c'est la violence
continuons
la pollinien c'est le sens
le dionysiaque c'est l'absurde
la polyné c'est la forme
le dionysiaque c'est la force
la polynéen c'est la poésie
le dionysiaque c'est la musique
la polynien c'est le travail
le dionysiaque C'est la fête
l'embauche et la débauche
continuons encore
la polynéen c'est le jour
le dionysiaque c'est la nuit
la polynien c'est le soleil le
dionysiaque c'est la lune
le soleil est toujours complet
ces lettres
la Lune passe par des phases
c'est le devenir
c'est amusant
la poulie 1 c'est l'individu
c'est la distinction
le dionysax c'est le tout
c'est l'indexinction
la polymien c'est le connaissable
ce que quand appelait le phénomène
le dionysiaque c'est l'inconnaissance
la chose en soi
remarquez à quel point ces antinomies
cohabitent en chacun de nous
au sein de la vie et du monde
le jour nous travaillons
les choses ont un sens un sens logique
rationnel
nous échangeons avec nos semblables
sur le mode du Logos et dans la paix
nous suivons une routine
la régularité
l'ordre
la nuit nous devenons quelqu'un d'autre
ce qui avait du sens le jour ne vient
absurde
nous nous abandonnons à l'ivresse
à la passion
à la violence
la nuit tout est imprévisible
tout est chaotique
rien n'est régulier
et en même temps
nous avons la sensation de toucher la
réalité de notre condition
la nuit et le soubassement du jour
car le jour
c'est de la nuit plus de la lumière
on dit que le soleil est clair
et quand on éclairant il révèle
et c'est le contraire
en éclairant
il cache
la lumière du soleil c'est ce qui cache
les étoiles
c'est ce qui empêche de contempler le
ciel
tel qu'il est vraiment
ce que nous dit Nietzsche c'est que si
apollon est le dieu de la lumière
c'est parce qu'il est le dieu du
recouvrement
du recouvrement de la pulsion par la
raison
tu recouvrement de l'absurdité par le
sens
soubassement de l'existence est absurde
et on a beau recouvrir cette absurdité
par la raison par l'ordre par le travail
ou par la forme
ce ne sont que des artifices
les artifices destinés à nous faire
oublier le tragique de l'existence pour
nous la rendre supportable
la polynien c'est la réponse humaine à
l'insupportabilité de l'absurdité du
monde
je cite
nous aurons fait un grand pas en ce qui
concerne la science esthétique quand
nous en serons arrivés non seulement à
l'induction logique mais encore à la
certitude immédiate de cette pensée que
l'évolution progressive de l'art et le
résultat du double caractère de l'esprit
apollinien et de l'esprit dionysien de
la même manière que la dualité des sexes
engendre la vie au milieu de lutte
perpétuelle et par des rapprochements
seulement périodiques ces noms nous les
empruntons au grec qui ont rendu
intelligibles au penseur le sens occulte
et profond de leur conception de l'art
n'ont pas aux moyens de notions mais à
l'aide des figures nettement
significatives du monde de leur Dieu
c'est alors divinité des arts Apollon et
Dionysos que se rattache notre
conscience de l'extraordinaire
antagonisme tant d'origine que de fin
qui exista dans le monde grec entre
l'art plastique apollinien et l'art
dénué de forme la musique l'art de
Dionysos
ces deux instincts impulsifs s'en vont
côte à côte en guerre ouverte le plus
souvent est excitant mutuellement à des
créations nouvelles toujours plus
robustes pour perpétuer par elle le
conflit de cette antagoniste que
l'appellation art qui leur est commune
ne fait que masquer jusqu'à ce qu'enfin
par un miracle métaphysique de la
volonté hellénique ils apparaissent
accouplés et que dans cet accouplement
ils engendrent alors l'oeuvre à la fois
dionysienne et apollinienne de la
tragédie hatique figurons-nous tout
d'abord pour les mieux comprendre ces
deux instincts comme les mondes
esthétiques différents du rêve et de
l'ivresse phénomène physiologique entre
lesquels on remarque un contraste
analogue à celui qui distingue l'un de
l'autre l'esprit apollinien et l'esprit
dionysien l'apparence pleine de beauté
des mondes du rêve dans la production
desquelles tout homme est un artiste
complet et la condition préalable de
tout art plastique et certainement aussi
d'une partie essentielle de la poésie
nous éprouvons de la jouissance à la
compréhension immédiate de la forme
toutes les formes nous parlent nul n'est
indifférente aucune n'est inutile et
pourtant la vie la plus intense de cette
réalité de rêve nous laisse encore le
sentiment confus qu'elle n'est qu'une
apparence l'homme doué d'un esprit
philosophique a même le pressentiment
que derrière la réalité dans laquelle
nous existons et vivons ils s'en cache
une autre toute différente et que par
conséquent la première née elle aussi
qu'une apparence et shopenhawer définit
formellement comme étant le signe
distinctif de l'aptitude philosophique
la faculté pour certains de se
représenter parfois les hommes et toutes
les choses comme de pures fantômes des
images de rêve et bien l'homme doué
d'une sensibilité artistique se comporte
à l'égard de la réalité du rêve de la
même manière que le philosophe en face
de la réalité de l'existence il examine
minutieusement et volontiers car dans
ces tableaux il découvre une
interprétation de la vie à l'aide de ses
exemples il s'exerce pour la vie
long comme divinité éthique exige des
siens la mesure et pour la pouvoir
conserver la connaissance de soi-même et
ainsi à l'exigence esthétique de la
beauté nécessaire vient s'ajouter la
discipline de ses préceptes connait
toi-même et ne va pas trop loin tandis
que l'autre cuit danse et l'exagération
sont les démons hostiles de la sphère
non-apollinienne et en cette qualité
appartient dans propre à l'époque hantée
apollinienne à l'ère des Titans et au
monde extra apollinien c'est-à-dire au
monde barbares à cause de son titanesque
amour de l'humanité Prométhée dû être
déchiré par le vautour pour sa trop
grande sagesse qui lui fit deviner
l'énigme du Sphinx
œdipe fut entraîné dans un tourbillon
inextricable de monstrueux forfait c'est
ainsi que le Dieu de DELF interprétait
le passé grec de même au grec apollinien
paraissaient titanesque et barbare
l'émotion provoquée par l'État
dionysiaque et cela sans qu'il pue
pourtant se dissimuler l'affinité
profonde qui le rattacher à ses Titans
vaincus et assez héros et du même
ressentir quelque chose de plus son
existence entière avec toute sa beauté
et sa mesure reposait sur l'abîme caché
du mal et de la connaissance et l'esprit
dionysien lui montrait de nouveau le
fond du gouffre et cependant Apollon ne
puisse vivre sans Dionysos le Titanic le
barbare fut en dernier ressort une aussi
impérieuse nécessité que la polymiens
imaginons maintenant comment du
raisonner à travers ce monde
artificiellement endigué de l'apparence
et de la mesure l'ivresse extatique des
fêtes de Dionysos en mélodie enchantée
et séductrice comme en séchant éclata
semblable à un cri déchirant tout
l'excès démesuré de la nature en joie
douleur et connaissances
représentons-nous ce qui pouvait valoir
regarde ce cœur démoniaque des voix du
peuple lapsalmodie de l’artiste
apollinien scandé par les sons étouffés
des harpes les Muses des arts de
l'apparence pâlirent un qui proclamait
la vérité dans son ivresse à la sérénité
olympienne la sagesse de Silène cria
malheur malheur l'individu avec toute sa
pondération et sa mesure s'écroula dans
l'oubli de soi-même de l'État dionysien
et oublia les préceptes apolliniens le
démesuré se révéla vérité le conflit
sentimental l'extase naît de la douleur
jaillissent spontanément du cœur de la
nature et c'est ainsi que partout où
pénétra l'esprit dionysien l'influence
apollinienne fut brisée et anéantie
pour Nietzsche la rencontre du
dionysiaque et de la polynéen n'est pas
seulement au fondement de la tragédie
grecque
elle est au fondement de la vie
elle-même
l'existence est absurde
le monde est absurde
et cette absurdité
nous devons l'accepter
nous devons l'aimer
amor Fati
aime ton destin
aime ce qui est
comme si ce qui est devait revenir
éternellement
il ne s'agit pas de se convaincre que la
vie a un sens
ni que
la souffrance n'existe pas
il s'agit de tout aimer dans la vie
de tout embrasser dans la vie
t'embrasser son absurdité
d'embrasser
la souffrance qu'elle nous inflige
d'embrasser la vie sous toutes ses
formes
embrassait veut dire prendre dans ses
bras
artiste n'est pas celui qui nie la vie
qui la modifie pour la rendre
supportable
l'artiste n'est pas celui qui embellit
le monde
qui le maquille
artiste et celui qui nous livre le monde
en plein visage
il est celui dont la nature s'empare
pour qu'il réinjecte dans la nature
ce qui anime la nature
pour que la nature
se renouvelle sans cesse à travers nous
se transcende elle-même
et pour que chaque jour soit comme la
musique
d'une danse perpétuelle
je vous remercie
[Musique]